>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> David Rowell: Michael Cunningham
has written a new book called A Wild
Swan: And Other Tales and he's
brought his friend Yuko Shimizu
who has done extraordinary
illustrations for the book.
You know, like you
all I know Michael
through his work and
through his books.
I've been lucky because I was also
able to publish some of his fiction
and nonfiction over the years as
an editor, but also I just wanted
to pass on it was exactly 20 years
ago that I got to study with Michael
for a week at the Provincetown
Fine Arts Work Center.
And so what you do is send in
two short stories, you know,
as an audition and then you
hope that they go over well
and that accepts you, so it was my
good fortune to have that happen.
So, you know, we were already in awe
of Michael because of the two books
that we knew, and so from
the very first day he came in
and he started talking about this
other book that he was working on
and he said, you know it's
got Virginia Woolf in it
and it has ghosts, I don't
really know what I'm doing,
but I don't know I
kind of love it and I'm
into it and, you know, we'll see.
Who knows what it's going to be?
And for those of us
aspiring writers, you know,
just to hear an author like this,
you know, won't give us any crumbs
at all was just remarkable.
And, you know, he was kind
of showing us what it is
to be vulnerable and
to also have a project
that you're not necessarily
always in charge of
but the work is the
thing and he said,
you know I'm just it feels right,
I don't know where it's going.
And so we were just kind
of knocked out by that.
You know, we felt in those days
like we were part of his circle.
Michael said a couple of things
during that week that I just want
to share with you because they've
stayed with me ever since and one
of them was, you know, he was
just talking about his writing
and at some point he said that he
basically considered any paragraph
that he wrote to be
or what he wanted it
to be was a bouquet of sentences.
I never heard that before and
I've never heard it after.
And if you know Michael's work
you know just how true that rings
because Michael is such
an incredible stylist
and he shapes his sentences
so beautifully
and what he was saying was the
effect of the paragraph, you know,
it's not that every sentence is
trying to out do the other sentence.
It's how you put them together.
It's the effect, and that whole
week he was so trying to kind
of push us toward imagery that
was startling and original.
And he said, you know, if you write
a line and it says lips are as red
as apples, then you know
that's not good enough.
You have to push yourself, you
don't want anything that's familiar.
And so that had a huge impact
on me as an aspiring writer
and the other thing a little bit
more perverse that he shared was,
so you know, you send in these
two short stories and at the end
of the time or at some point in the
time he talks to you about them.
And so we were always
in anticipation
of have you had your
time with Michael yet?
You know and so mine was at the
very end, and so we sat down
and he had my two manuscripts
and he said, so okay, okay.
He read them and he said, you know,
basically I think that this story
and he held the other one up and he
said I think that this story should
and I wasn't quite sure
where he was going.
And I can't say the actual word
that he said, but since we're
in Washington I'm going
to choose have relations.
[laughter] So he said
basically I think
that this story should have
relations with this story
and what comes out of that
is what you should be doing.
[laughter] So when
you've heard something
like that you can never quite
look at eight and a half
by eleven paper quite
in the same way.
[laughter] But I also understood
what he was saying and so, you know,
in many ways what I've been trying
to do ever since then is work
on the baby for those two stories.
[laughter] Anyway, so
as you know, Michael,
that book that he was talking
about then went on to be The Hours,
went on to win the Pulitzer Prize.
He is the author of other books such
as Specimen Days and Darkness Falls
and The Snow Queen and a
beautiful book about Provincetown
and the spirit and
beauty of that town.
And Yuko whose work I mean
basically you know her work
from everywhere you look.
She has had work in Rolling
Stone and The New Yorker,
the cover of books,
Time, and Newsweek,
but also she's created
this incredible poster.
[applause] So hopefully she can
talk to us a little bit about that.
So let's welcome them to the stage.
Michael Cunningham and Yuko Shimizu.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Michael Cunningham: Are we set?
Are we audible?
>> David Rowell: Can
everyone hear us?
Yes?
>> Michael Cunningham: Great, great.
David, thank you.
That was so by the way, you
turned out awfully well.
I have the temerity
to be proud of you.
Am I tell me if I'm not
audible in the back, okay?
But, yeah, yeah.
20 years ago two stories got married
and produced generations
of younger stories.
>> David Rowell: Right.
>> Michael Cunningham: I
remember that conversation.
>> David Rowell: So stories,
I mean you know a lot of us
who are short story
lovers have wondered
when Michael might ever
publish a short story collection
and here we have it.
This is the book.
And so basically I kind
of think of this book
as Michael being a great jazz
pianist who is playing the standards
which is to say there are
some stories that, you know,
he maybe plays a little
bit straighter,
some he totally reverses, some
he bends the bridge or the verse,
and some he just totally reimagines.
So I mean it's thrilling to see
what he does with each story.
Each story is different.
So one of the things,
Michael, I wonder about is
so in this book you have kings
and jesters and spells and castles
but you also have clothing
my Marc Jacobs.
>> Michael Cunningham: Right.
>> David Rowell: And subway
turnstiles and apartments with cable
and a part, you know, bars
where people go for hookups,
and so I'm wondering if
you felt like you had
to establish any kind
of rules going into it.
How the contemporary would
speak to or intersect
with the traditional kingdom.
>> Michael Cunningham: You know,
that was one of those things
that sort of the came
out as I wrote.
You know, these are these
sort of reinterpreted,
reimagined fairy tales and
as far as I can tell most
of the fairy tales I knew as a kid,
most of the ones I sort of retold
in this book are medieval
kings, castles, you know,
yeah sort of vaguely 13 to 1400s.
And there was something
it's hard to some
of this stuff is hard
to be specific about.
It felt a little kitsch setting them
in their original fairy tale time,
but then it also felt
sort of contrived
to set them in contemporary times.
You know, you're kind of damned if
you do, damned this way and damned
that way and I thought if I
if there are kings and castles
and laundromats and strip
malls, maybe it will just sort
of lift them out of time.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh.
>> Michael Cunningham: So
that by the juxtaposition
of of our lives now and the 14th
century, we're not sort of thinking
so much about the time in
which these stories take place.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh, uh huh.
>> Michael Cunningham:
It could be any time.
>> David Rowell: Sure.
And so were the stories completely
finished before you turned to Yuko,
or was she brought into
the process at some point?
Or talk about how she
became part of the book.
>> Michael Cunningham: Well, I
would love to turn it over to Yuko,
but the stories were pretty
much finished and it was clear
that a book of fairy
tales needs illustrations.
And we had a hard time
finding anybody who felt right.
The book was published by Farrar,
Strauss and Giroux, a great
and venerable publishing
house and I sort of imagined
that they would have reams
of illustrators to call.
They don't.
[laughter] They don't really.
They had some children's
books illustrators but nobody
who felt I kind of had a
vague idea of the sensibility
which would be sort of you
know perverse but beautiful.
I had a rough sense of the
artists we were looking for
and we weren't finding that person,
and I finally just
Googled illustrators.
[laughter] And came up with Yuko.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Wait is
that how you found me?
>> Michael Cunningham: Yeah.
[laughter] They didn't
tell you that.
>> Yuko Shimizu: No, no, no.
>> Michael Cunningham:
I Googled you.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Oh,
I had zero idea.
>> Michael Cunningham: No one at God
damned FSG was doing shit about it.
Excuse me, I'm sorry.
It's turrets like I will
try to watch my language.
>> Yuko Shimizu: I got a call
from the cover art director
in [inaudible] FSG who I
actually had worked with in past.
And he, you know, he mentioned
like you know Michael wrote these
short stories and he want this
to be illustrated and what
do you think about it.
And like we think, you
know, you're a perfect match
and like I just assumed he
found me because, you know,
I have worked with him before, but
it was a completely different kind
of book because I'm a
Japanese and I do a lot
of you know Japanese period
style art and it was one
of [inaudible] books so it
was very period Japanese,
woodblock print type of work.
It's very different.
>> Michael Cunningham: Yeah, yeah.
>> Yuko Shimizu: So I'm finding
out something very interesting.
>> Michael Cunningham:
I know, I know, I know.
I don't mind if Rodrigo
took credit for it,
but in fact, it was me, girl.
I found you all by myself.
[laughter]
>> Yuko Shimizu: Thank you.
>> David Rowell: So
>> Michael Cunningham: Just
quickly there was it's incredible
work online.
It was very Asian, but I
thought oh, the sensibility
that doesn't that's no problem.
You know, that's anybody who can
do what you can do can do anything.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Thank you.
>> David Rowell: So, Yuko,
you know we all kind of grew
up with those stories but
also a style of illustration
with those stories often, and I
wonder how you went about kind
of sorting through your
own sense of parameters.
Did you feel liberated from the kind
of traditional approach the
way these are often illustrated
or did you feel like you
needed to work within that?
>> Yuko Shimizu: So it was a
very interesting creative process
because nowadays, you know,
everyone knows in any field
like nobody have meetings.
I mean especially if you're a
freelancer and nobody calls.
Like everything is on email and
so I don't see any of my clients.
I don't see any of my
collaborators for a very long time,
but FSG actually called
us to be in the meeting.
So we had multiple meetings
throughout the stages,
different stages, maybe
three or four times.
>> Michael Cunningham: Yeah.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Over
the course of start
to finish initially
like let's sit and talk.
You know like what are you
thinking, what Michael is thinking,
what we as a publisher are thinking.
Let's come together and talk.
And so that was a start and then
also Michael said like Yuko,
I'm an artist, you know I write
and that's what I do
and you're an artist.
You draw, that's what you know
how to do, so I picked you
and I completely trust what you
do and you come up with something,
you know, that you feel is right.
And of course then like a meeting
follows and I went to Books
of Wonder which is a
children's bookstore
and which is probably mostly known
as the model of You've Got Mail.
That's where Meg Ryan works.
[laughter] And it's an old location.
I asked them actually, it's an
old old nice children's bookstore
and actually it's right on
the first floor of FSG office,
so I went in there and they have
like different sections not
just a contemporary kids books
but they have a rare book
section and they also
that have republished old books.
So I read Michael's
almost completely finished,
you did a little bit of editing
but it was almost completely
finished set of stories,
and it feels like it's right to
use sort of like turn of the 19th
to 20th century children's
book from, you know,
mainly Europe like England.
Like really dark line based work
that was popular around that period.
And because I do black
and white line work
and okay this direction my work
and I went in before the meeting
and bought whole bunch of books
from time period and then brought
that in and we started talking.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh.
>> Yuko Shimizu: And then
from there, you know,
like every time I do
some sketches we meet
and every time I do some
more finished we meet
and then gradually moved forward.
>> David Rowell: And, Michael,
were there images or things
that she had seized on within
your stories that surprised you?
>> Michael Cunningham: Yes.
And in the best possible sense.
You want to be surprised.
You hope to be pleasantly
surprised and yeah, yeah.
As Yuko said, I felt like, you know,
I just want do whatever you want.
I mean although this the
prose came before the images.
I wanted it to be a collaboration.
I wanted Yuko to use the
stories as a departure point
for whatever she wanted to
do, and they started coming
in and they were ravishing.
I said I just showed them
to people and say, okay,
you're not going to
believe this one.
And I know you we talk about
it, there were a few times
where you thought either this or
that and we talked about that,
but essentially what's
in the published version are exactly
the drawings you you produced.
They're fantastic.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Thank you.
>> Michael Cunningham: They're it
was really interesting to me to see
which image from the
story spoke to you.
And I feel like we talk about
two stories getting married,
I feel like this book is a
sort of marriage of the stories
and your illustration which
are distinctly related
but the illustrations are not
subsidiaries of the stories.
The illustrations are
almost a book of their own.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh, uh huh.
So let's talk about
some of these stories.
I mean some of the tales that
you take on are Snow White.
>> Michael Cunningham: Uh huh.
>> David Rowell: And Rumpelstiltskin
and Jack and the Beanstalk
and Beauty and the
Beast and Monkey's Paw
which is not doesn't
always show up in those.
>> Michael Cunningham:
That's a bit of a cheat.
I know. That's not
really a fairy tale.
I just figured it's my
book, I can do what I want.
>> David Rowell: Of course.
[laughter] So I want to talk
about and you, I'll take your cues
because there may be some specifics
about stories that you don't want
to give away or reveal,
but I'd love to talk
about the Rumpelstiltskin story
if we could a little bit because
and one of the things that's so
great about this book is, you know,
the villains the people
we're not rooting
for in these books are generally,
you know, kind of one dimensional
in the stories that we have read.
>> Michael Cunningham:
Right, right, right, right.
>> David Rowell: And so what Michael
has done consistently is he's taken
some of those characters
and it's almost as if that's
where his sympathies lie, or
at least there's a curiosity
and he steps back and
he says, well lets kind
of maybe probe a little bit
about how this character
maybe got to this point.
And Rumpelstiltskin so you know with
Rumpelstiltskin there is that notion
that he wants the woman
who becomes the queen,
he wants the queen's
daughter and of course we grew
up thinking, well how horrible.
Why should Rumpelstiltskin
have a child?
He's single, you know,
he's a hunchback.
[laughter] He's you
know he's small, right.
That would be the worst thing,
and so and Michael's take,
Michael from the very
beginning of that story says,
why shouldn't he have a child?
What's wrong with Rumpelstiltskin
wanting a child?
>> Michael Cunningham: Yeah.
>> David Rowell: So did that
impulse to kind of shift
in some ways the point not the
point of view so much but to focus
on the different character
than what we are used to,
was that a plan going
into the entire project?
>> Michael Cunningham: It was, you
know I hardly ever have anything
as useful as a plan, but I have
a sort of sense of smell almost
about what I'm doing and then
it begins to reveal itself
as some kind of something plan like.
And I think maybe the sort of
underlying notion of this book is,
as you say, the traditional
fairy tales
which I love, these are homages.
They're not wiseacre
rifts on archaic forms.
>> David Rowell: Right.
There's something ironic, yes.
>> Michael Cunningham: These
are stories that I still love
and the characters are in fact
almost inevitably one-dimensional.
They're evil or they're
good, you know.
They're virginal or they're corrupt
and without being so conscious
of it I guess I was thinking,
but what if they were all
more complicated than that?
>> David Rowell: Right.
>> Michael Cunningham: What if
I being a 21st century writer,
though I dwelt long in the 20th
century as well, I mean it's all
about like most contemporary
fiction writers human complexity.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh.
>> Michael Cunningham: There's
no good guy, there's no bad guy.
We're all the good
guy and the bad guy.
It depends on the day, it
depends on the situation.
And you mentioned earlier that some
of the fairy tales hue pretty
closely to the originals
and others don't, and what I found
was it was kind of interesting.
That if you if you try to imagine
why Rumpelstiltskin would want a
child so so much, what would
lead a girl to fall in love
with essentially a seven foot
yeti in a great coat and a saber?
If you follow the characters,
some of them demanded very different
versions of the traditional stories
and some of them made the
same story all over again.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh.
>> Michael Cunningham: Which
says something about destiny
that I'm not smart
enough to quite tackle.
But you know what I'm saying?
That some of the existing fairy
tales had room for characters
with free will and free
choice and so went exactly
where the fairy tale went anyway and
some of them went somewhere else.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh, uh huh.
So I know that, Michael, as a child
your parents read these stories
to you very often and they
meant a great deal to you.
Yuko, I'm wondering what your
relationship was to these stories
as a child or later in life or
>> Yuko Shimizu: I my
parents did read a lot to me
and then also I was a bookworm.
You know like someone who it's
like after lunch outside it's sunny
and everyone is going outside and
doing dodge ball and I'm the one
who is staying inside and either
reading books or drawing pictures.
>> Michael Cunningham:
Uh huh, uh huh.
>> Yuko Shimizu: You
know so I did know,
except for Monkey Paw I didn't
know, but I knew all the stories.
It's interesting, you know, my
friends and people I know read it
and there are always different
stories they don't know
like I didn't know this,
I didn't know that.
And there are not many people
who knew every one of them
but fairy tales are
interesting because Disney has
like since very sort of
like sanitized everything,
but it's really dark and, you
know, tragic often and not many
of them have happy endings.
So in that sense Michael's book is
more true to the actual fairy tales
than Disney's stories are.
It's like fascinating I ask people
like do you know how Little
Mermaids end at the end and most
of the people don't know.
Most of the kids don't know.
I teach college art school and many
of the college students don't
know and that worries me.
Like it's almost like bringing back
what is real in a 21st century way.
>> Michael Cunningham:
Would you remind us
of how the Little Mermaid
actually ends.
[laughter]
>> Yuko Shimizu: You
remember, right?
>> Michael Cunningham: I do.
I do.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Yes.
You so like she kills
herself, right?
Like because he, the
prince, picks the other woman
who he thought saved him who didn't.
The little mermaid saved
but she couldn't say it
and then he picked her
and they get married
and then the contract was she
can get him and she will either
like turn like yeah she
has to kill herself.
So she kills herself but she
turns into like a water bubble
and travels around the world.
I think that's the ending, right?
>> Michael Cunningham:
Yeah, that's the ending.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Yes.
>> Michael Cunningham: Okay.
Just quickly Sleeping
Beauty, the prince gets
into the tower and kisses her.
No effect.
He goes off, he does other things,
he thinks you know I've just been
thinking about that comatose girl
so he goes back and kisses her again
and this time she wakes
up but she's pregnant.
This is the true original
Sleeping Beauty
because what he we
know what he did to her
that first time while
she was comatose.
[laughter] It wasn't just a kiss.
This is the Sleepy Beauty
as originally conceived.
I did not darken these fairy tales.
I did not make them more perverse.
>> Yuko Shimizu: No, and then Snow
White kills the evil stepmother
at the end.
>> Michael Cunningham: Yeah, yeah.
That one I've always liked
that one in particular.
>> Yuko Shimizu: Do you know this?
If you don't please read them.
We're not making this up.
[laughter]
>> Michael Cunningham: I think Snow
White is an especially interesting
one because, you know, yeah,
she kills the stepmother.
By the way, the prince is
just riding through the forest
and he sees a dead girl in a
glass coffin and kisses her.
What's that about?
[ Laughter ]
>> Yuko Shimizu: There must be
something wrong with him, right?
>> Michael Cunningham: Well,
you know a kiss you know
if a beautiful corpse is still a
corpse and it's a stranger and it's
in the woods, and there's seven
little people huddled around it,
I might not kiss that girl.
[laughter] Or I might,
but you know, it's just
>> Yuko Shimizu: I won't.
>> Michael Cunningham:
It's there are you're I'm
so glad you're pointing
this out because they're so,
they're so fabulously
peculiar and perverse and dark
and the ones the Disney
versions that certainly I grew
up with this is a whole
other conversation.
But I don't hate the
Disney versions.
I have complicated feelings
about being so terrified
about the Arthur Rackham
illustrations
in the childhood book I grew
up with that I couldn't,
I couldn't go into the
room where it was kept.
[laughter] Like I wanted
to hear the stories.
>> Yuko Shimizu: He was my
favorite artist growing up.
>> Michael Cunningham: But
they just so freaked me out.
And like I said, I think the whole
the sanitized Disney versions are
not a good thing, they're
a complicated thing.
>> David Rowell: But
speaking of the complications,
Michael is the only writer who
would take the sort of Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs and think about
later, okay so they're together
but at some point she feels
obligated to have the dwarfs
over for a dinner party
and they kind of resent him
and so later they're talking
about the dinner party
like oh yeah, that went well.
[laughter] So, you know,
I mean one of the things
that Michael is constantly doing
in these stories is he is
you know these stories seem
to be very ridged in their ending.
They're very final in one sense
that good has triumphed over evil
and what else is there to know.
But Michael, you know, in these
stories comes in and says but what
about the next day, and
maybe six years from now.
How are things going in the castle?
And you know I mean that ambiguity
is I mean what all writers want
ambiguity, of course, but
it also keeps these stories
from being predictable
because there's
so many surprises in each of them.
>> Michael Cunningham:
Yeah, yeah, I hope so.
You know that actually
stems from my childhood
when we would my mother mostly
would read these fairy tales to me
and she would get to and
they lived happily ever after
and it took me a long
time to get over this.
I would look at her like go on.
And she would say, no that's
the end and I would say,
no that can't be the end.
What happens what happens to the
prince with the one swan wing?
What if Snow White
doesn't like the castle?
What if, what if, what if?
And she would just kind
of light a cigarette
and say, well that's the end.
[ Laughter ]
Go to bed.
So I had to do, I had
to do the work myself.
>> David Rowell: So this is
a question for both of you
and I'll start with you, Michael.
If you had tried this project
10 years ago or 20 years ago,
do you imagine that these you would
have brought different inclinations,
insights [inaudible]
to these stories?
Would they have been very
different do you think?
>> Michael Cunningham: Wow.
You know I, I, I imagine
they would have been.
I mean I hope so.
You hope you're not the same writer
10 years or 20 years down the line.
I was just talking to
somebody about this yesterday.
This is I think they would have
I suspect they would have been
different in at least one way
that comes immediately to mind.
Twenty years ago when I was 50 I no
when I was younger, say in my 20s,
I was, I was so dead
set against anything
that suggested sentimentality.
As young people often are,
as my students often are.
Some of my most brilliant students
are just so terrified of sentiment
that what they produce is
barren and like, you know,
like an ice cube, and
we talk about that.
And I certainly now that I am know
longer in my 20s, I no longer feel
like oh, anything that isn't barren
and hopeless and wind blasted
and without any nourishment
or kindness
to speak of is no use to me.
>> David Rowell: Ha ha.
>> Michael Cunningham: I'm not
that guy anymore, you know.
>> David Rowell: Sure.
>> Michael Cunningham: I hope,
I hope I haven't gotten mushy,
but I certainly at this age am not
as opposed to rampant expressions
of love and sorrow as I would
have been when I was younger.
>> David Rowell: Yuko,
how about you?
If this had been a project
much earlier in your career.
>> Yuko Shimizu: I bet it would
be different and I teach college,
college level art students
and illustrations classes
and I also went to the same
school as a student and going
through four years as a
student then started teaching
and I've been teaching there
for I think 12 or 13 years,
fairy tales often come up
as a subject for assignments
because everyone knows fairy tales.
Everyone has relationship
with fairy tales.
It's kind of an easy topic
to give as to students
but at the same time it's one
of the hardest because like ever
since we were little child like
we're bombarded with imagery
like Disney or not, you
know, like dark or happy.
Image of children's books from,
you know, like Grimm and Andersen
and all those famous stories and
we have certain ideas in our head.
It's really really
difficult to get away from it.
So if I don't give my students
intentionally fairy tale assignment
because it's they will come
out with something like yeah,
I've already seen that before
and like why are you
drawing Snow White this way?
That's how you remember
from Disney movies.
So there are all these
things that is
like keeping you from
freeing yourself.
So like going back to your question,
I hope I'm a better
artist than when I started.
I've been doing this for
about 15 years or so,
and so if I got this
assignment 15 years ago,
I would have tried my best but like
how much how good would I have been
to get away from these
images that traps us?
And the better you get, the
more sophisticated you get
as a visual artist or writer
or any kind of art form,
you know like is getting away from
and it makes it easier for you
to come out with something that is
fresh, and it's really hard to do
at early stage in your career.
>> David Rowell: Uh huh.
>> Yuko Shimizu: So I'm glad
that I got it maybe like 12 years
into my career and how I
remember this is the first time
so the art director Rodrigo
who designed this cover too
and he called me and he said like,
you know, Michael is interested
in your work so like are you
interested in working with this.
Like I'm calling you
because you're not like one
of those young young talented
artists who can't handle this yet.
I think you have enough
experience to handle
like I clearly remember had I
said like you're not just a kid,
I think you can handle this.
So that's my answer.
>> Michael Cunningham:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> David Rowell: Well,
I have the feeling
that this is probably a group that
would like to ask some questions,
so in the time we have left,
we have about 10 minutes,
there are two microphones
that if there are questions we
could certainly we have time, sure.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> I'm just curious about
cultural differences.
About 25 years ago I worked in
advertising in Tokyo and one
of my clients, I was a
copywriter, was Shiseido.
And so my boss a Japanese woman
came to me I said I want you
to promote this skin cream because
it brings harmony to a woman's life.
And I'm going because I was
selling to western women and I had
to convince her that's
not going to work.
[laughter] So I'm wondering if
you had any cultural differences
in working as a writer
and illustrator.
>> Yuko Shimizu: The cultural
difference that me coming
from different background
or cultural difference
between artist and writer?
>> You being Japanese.
>> Oh, I being Japanese.
I actually grew up here as a kid so
like I'm a Japanese citizen still
and I still have lived in Japan
longer than I have lived here,
but I went middle stool in U.S.,
and so that's when you know a
kid develop their personal ID
and you know like sense of identity.
So since then I went
back to Japan when I was
in high school and
then came back here.
I always feel like I'm
neither, so I'm half and half
or like you know both and
I miss I lack little bit
of like American common sense.
I lack a little bit of
Japanese common sense
but I'm also well rounded in both.
You know like you can't be double,
you can't have like perfect both,
so I think I'm pretty good and of
course as an artist who is working
with my name attached like I have
to like what I have to do is I have
to do something that is fresh.
>> Right.
>> Yuko Shimizu: And if my being
hybrid makes it fresh like and if
that works, that's enough for me.
>> Michael did you
feel any difference or
>> Michael Cunningham:
Not working with Yuko
but when I was writing the stories
I read more nonwestern fairy tales
than I had before and
Asian fairy tales,
African fairy tales
are really different.
>> Yes.
>> Michael Cunningham:
Profoundly different in their sense
of the stories a child
should be told.
A lot of them are much more of
them are neolistic [phonetic],
western fairy tales one must much
more to moral improvement than a lot
of Asian and African fairy tales.
But finally, it was a bit of a
no brainer because I just felt
like in another kind of book, you
want to try to transcend to the best
of your ability your localness, your
Americanness, your tiny little head
in your tiny little life.
But I could not it would
have felt so fraudulent.
>> Yeah.
>> Michael Cunningham: To
try to reimagine stories
that were not the stories
I was told as a child.
That would have felt
like some kind of creepy
>> Yeah. You're talking
about being American,
one of the things I'll never forget
was my boss was, he wasn't my boss
but I worked with him, a creative
director, he was Japanese,
he didn't even speak English,
he had never been to the U.S.
But I taught him a little bit of
English and he would introduce me
and say, this is Nan
san, my name is Nan,
she's from New York but she's nice.
[ Laughter ]
>> Michael Cunningham: Thank you.
>> David Rowell: Yes.
>> I was wondering have you ever
thought of trying a different style
when it comes to drawing?
Maybe something more
like art nouveau.
>> Yuko Shimizu: For this?
>> No, for anything.
>> Yuko Shimizu: If the
right project comes up.
So like the job of an illustrator
is like you know try to do my thing
and at the same time like
pick some concept that works
with the problem I need to solve.
For this problem like how I needed
to solve was a turn of the 19th
to 20th century European
children's book style.
So if any project comes up
that calls for art nouveau,
I would do it, but at this
point I haven't seen it yet,
so that's why I haven't done it.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> David Rowell: Yes.
>> Michael, you mentioned
sentimentality earlier
and about avoiding it.
I was just wondering this is
a question for both of you
if you're concerned, if
something whether it's art
or literature is too sentimental
then it lapses into kitsch
or it lapses into the territory
of being sappy or trite.
Is that something that
both of you try to avoid
and how do you avoid that?
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Michael Cunningham: I'll go.
I'm really talking about veering
closer to the edge of sentimentality
which is as opposed to
saying 10 miles away from it
so that there's no danger that
you'll ever be maudlin or mawkish.
As I grow older I'm more interested
not only as a writer but as a reader
in work that sort of acknowledges
our emotionality and is willing
to risk going a little too far.
And the trick is trying never
to go too far and I'm fortunate
in having a small body of
terrifically cruel friends
who are readers who are merciless
and I really I have to say
that without Ken Corbet
[phonetic] and Marie How [phonetic]
and Adam Moss [phonetic]
and several other people,
I can't imagine how I would do
this because one of their jobs is
to say, honey that's too much.
[laughter] And I have the
good sense to listen to them.
>> Yuko Shimizu: So from
the artist's point of view,
I think it's like sentiment
is like well
like there are different definitions
so like looking back at something
and like oh that was nice and
try to like re create that.
And what I always keep in mind
is like regardless of what I feel
about that nostalgia or time period
I'm looking back to like we live now
and how to bring the
contemporary feel to something old.
If I'm like imitating something
old in this case, you know,
the old children's book or like
maybe art nouveau at some point,
if I just redraw what was then
there then it becomes kitsch
or it becomes just copy, so
I try to like put my mindset,
yes I'm doing this, I'm duplicating
the style but also I live now
and how to make it
look contemporary.
And there is no like
one way of doing that
but the mindset really
helps I think.
>> Thank you.
>> David Rowell: Okay.
We have time for one
more question, sure.
>> Michael, I have a question.
Earlier in your career you focused
on gay relationships in novels
and I'm a person who is writing
about controversial subjects
the way women are treated
in the hard sciences.
And I've received so much criticism
and I wonder if you could talk
to criticism you might
have gotten back
in the 90s I guess
in your first books.
>> Michael Cunningham: Oh, sure.
Could everybody hear that?
You know I, I've, I think
I've always written novels
in which there are gay characters,
more gay characters than are
in most books, but also straight
character, more straight characters
than there are in most books
with gay people in them.
[ Laughter ]
I think our situations
are different.
I think the world's
perception, I think,
I think the world tortures
women in ways slightly different
from the way it which
it tortures gay men.
I on one hand this stuff was
just sort of ignored, you know,
it was niche writing, it was,
it was the genre known as gay.
>> David Rowell: At the
back of the bookstore often.
>> Michael Cunningham: Yeah, yeah.
>> David Rowell: In
bookstores there's sort
of that one section
of gay literature.
>> Michael Cunningham: But I
have to say, a lot of people,
many of them gay, many
of them people whose sexual
orientation was whatever it was
but who were especially interested
in gay [inaudible] paid
particular attention.
It was, it wasn't planned, but it
was actually kind of helpful to be
out there writing about lives
that hadn't appeared much
if at all in fiction before.
And I'm, I'm still slightly
surprised even after all these years
that I got first I kind
of got out of the niche,
and then they just closed
the niche altogether.
There aren't gay sections
in bookstores anymore
and I for one don't
miss them, you know.
>> Exactly.
>> Michael Cunningham: Put the
books in with everybody else.
>> David Rowell: Right.
[ Applause ]
>> Do you have any advice for women
like myself writing
on these subjects?
>> Michael Cunningham:
Off the top of my head,
fuck anybody who gets in your way.
[laughter]
>> Thank you.
>> David Rowell: That's a
pretty good note to end on.
Let's have a round of
applause for Michael
and Yuko for joining us today.
[ Applause ]
Thanks everyone.
Thanks very much.